i had to call the manager and i say make
the phone call tell them uh you know
tell them your storage lock was
burglarized
makes the phone call calls me back said
there's no answer and i said okay i said
well uh plan b go knock on the door and
tell them you're the manager right
that's what a manager would do he goes
i'm not going to do that i go why not he
goes i just googled him he killed 19
people
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg hi oh my god
you guys on that side
over here i need a you know i'm waiting
for the draft podcast draft no congrats
uh aaron are we rolling
we've been wrong
uh all right well it's our pleasure
today to welcome one of the podcasts uh
retired fbi special agent uh scott is it
growler or gary gariola gary ola um
famous i mean you know you can you can
say how true this is or not but famous
for catching whitey bulger among other
many uh great criminals and in fact uh
there's a great podcast episode out
there about your uh investigation into
the chippendales murder for hire case
which my favorite highlight was there
was someone involved in that whose name
was gil lopez is that correct gilberto
gilberto lopez
relevant for our audience
i'm sure probably look like you he
wasn't wearing a mask
okay um yeah that's amazing i mean where
do we start um i think we should start
with what's topical what do you think is
going on even with that guy brian
laundry
i mean everybody's talking yeah i mean
it's it's it's we don't get too many of
those cases in l.a right people don't
disappear it's it's like uh it's like
the guy that did the uh land olympic
park bombing right he went in the woods
he lived for you know weeks maybe months
at a time they finally tracked him down
who knows it's anybody's guess right he
could be a alligator
right now yeah right he could be hiding
with some friends you know you don't
know
you know usually in our business it's
somebody's helping them out it's family
or friends
okay eric rudolph right
so eric rudolph how did he survive out
there and
don't they have like um
survivalist right he
like don't the camera don't the uh
helicopters in los angeles now
you used to
back in my day
you only just had to run from the light
they have heat shaking stuff now they
have heat sink but they got to go over
you too right ah and you got to make the
right place right right so because it
can't go through
trees and stuff so it can go through
something it can but
you've got to be if you're searching
here
if the helicopter's here and the body's
over here
you're not going to get the heat seeking
right if the body's hiding right here in
the hill every then you'll pick it up so
they've got to be able to have the
ability to fly within a certain area
yeah a circle to feel the heat and dogs
dogs are
you guys had great uh scent dogs yeah we
worked homicide cases together
some are alive some guys swear by them
and some guys say they'll never use them
again i've i've
i've used them and i haven't had
anything bad with them but before we go
any further he said as you heard
scott just said you guys use them you
know we were
scott was the best he was the guy that
go-to yeah you know we work the case we
work at them we say hey
here's our man here's what we need
it's like yo rinnie go
and and his people did he was just the
go-to the human guy
he was you know what and i find that
fascinating about you because you're not
really like a mamon to be giving
compliments but that was over and above
the if there was a [ __ ] bell in here
it'd be ringing my bone with
[ __ ] cream
introduction was just a little minimal
like i've done so much
i wish it was just longer do you think
we could go back in there and i could
sit there you know some guys are all
about the title which i don't which i
don't really get
that's why
you know when somebody says oh you know
my my dad's a singer you know you go to
[ __ ] elton john hey you know my dad
said oh yeah you want to piss somebody
off [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
you know fbi yeah my my cousin where's
my cousin like
he's a mailman oh they wasn't the
government uh you know just kind of
everybody's into minimalization and
that's why everybody on
youtube or podcasts
or in whatever form of media thinks that
they're sleuths you know everybody
thinks they can solve the crime plunder
and uh true rocket
uh
crime science whatever that dude's name
is so i've been watching this the chris
watch there's a lot of stuff but but
true crime rocket science this guy the
most authentic voice and true crime
uh i'll put these two guys against that
guy and his dog so this guy started
putting the schnauzer on and i like
crime everybody you want to [ __ ]
disinterest me i rescue dogs i don't
have to like them to rescue them i'm
sure when people are floating in the
ocean and they're help us there's some
people like hey i don't really you know
a couple latinos out there i'm not you
know i shouldn't be the one to go say
well you don't have issues with them
there's a guy who lived next door to
start his car four o'clock in the
morning here and i would go at it you
know i'm not the best i might drop them
you know so so when you see uh everybody
trying to be
a sleuth
because minimization takes
you guys you know they'll be like oh
they're
without the history and then those guys
are like well we you know we helped i've
i've done a podcast on
71 cases of murder but still doesn't
make you
know beneficial and and the benefit or
the probably the best part of this thing
is and i'm not here to bad mouth any
agency at all
but
because it's not about that the agency
is not there it was scott
i mean he dressed just like the way he
is today levi's and shirt you know no
suit and tie
there was no condescending there was
nothing it was a share of information
and these guys
and he was a worker bee
and was that was that was that was your
demeanor in your dress and the
conversation like was that a fbi
do they teach that or that's just your
own personality personality that's how
you grew up right i grew up in the bronx
you know working class parents
you know worked through i worked when i
was 11 years old in the grocery store
and you ever see it were you ever in
there when it got robbed
no we never got robbed okay there's a
nice section of the bronx that's good
yeah because kind of people looked out
for that's one thing about i think back
there the bronx and all the stuff that
people looked out in their neighborhood
in their blocks right you had kind of
blocked taking care of the own
uh neighborhood watch from back in the
day well it's funny you say that because
you know when i first started the fbi i
was working italian mob and i'm italian
so i remember going home and telling my
mother and say hey mom i'm working the
italian organized crime i said what are
you doing that voice says mustache pizza
used to protect the neighborhood you
know
when we were little girls we could walk
around anywhere in harlem and those were
the guys that looked down for us no one
that no one even made a pass at us
because of those guys you know so that's
the that's the mentality you know and
my parents were born in the 20s right so
that's the mentality they grew up with
but
you know i grew up hard-working parents
and i used to see the guys from the nypd
swinging you know billy clubs walking
down the street that's what i want to do
growing up wow you know i didn't see him
thumping anybody so if they called you a
flat foot it wasn't offensive to you nah
nah
that's what those guys were there called
flashlights
on the beat yeah so that's good was your
fault was anybody in law enforcement in
europe no law enforcement no law
enforcement with you either oh
absolutely not there's something inside
right yeah wow
you know because like muhammad ali
became a boxer because somebody stole
his bike
and then
a police officer told you that you're
kind of going down the wrong 17 he took
me told my parents signed for him to get
off the streets he'll end up in prison
or dead and he did the best thing that
ever happened to me
well
when that guy said you know get him off
the streets he's going to end up in
prison or dead
to go to vietnam
hey that matured me that made me have a
new appreciation you know and that's why
all i wanted to do was become a cop to
give back what he gave to me i have to
tell you man i mean
i i you know
when i was on the radio in 2000 out here
there was a shortage of police officers
in the lapd i'm pretty sure there still
is law enforcement across the country
and everywhere in the world and they
wanted me to do a
week of
telling people how easy it would be if
you wanted to ever thought about being a
police officer of a veteran all that you
you know we're gonna make it easy for
you and we went and did the car chases
out there off of the five freeway where
it's wet and you're kind of chasing the
cars around the tracks and then yeah
then they people pop up and you you know
you walk through the streets and you
just situations
and uh those guys had paintball they
were you know dressed in paper and i i
you know
i wouldn't let anybody shoot at me or i
wouldn't shoot the i wouldn't shoot the
gun they were like what's wrong with you
man and i said
you know i don't wanna i don't wanna aim
at anybody i don't wanna get shot i
don't wanna
i don't wanna get hit by anything
so i sat out there
so they uh so i was like and then i and
then i talked to this lady that does
your stars and then i said hey is there
a reason that i'm like not into you know
guns or
you know being shot at or i mean i got
shot at at a party in
10th grade
i was still running till [ __ ] last
thursday
where this guy comes into a house party
shoots it up
[ __ ] take off running and you hear
and it hit the
cement of some wall
and we turned into an alley and those
guys i still remember in the dark
they're going george my bucket
man i ran all the way about a mile and a
half i went through the park like
forrest gump through the car
the only thing i didn't go was the
appalachian trail
wow
so just it just kind of
triggers any of your buddies and all
that stuff that yeah you know growing up
in a bronx everybody wanted to be fdny
fire department nypd i so i left i came
out to school i went to ucla
and so i always had this kind of thing
in the back of my head and uh what was i
like to go to the bronx to be for the
bronx they go to ucla i remember i
remember in santa monica once crossing
the street against the don't walk sign
and
the copper got on the pa hey what are
you doing it says don't walk can't you
read whoa
anymore right
those [ __ ] turtles end up with
plastic straws in their mouths what are
you doing i don't go to starbucks every
day what the [ __ ] going on
and they got rid of all the plastic
though it's just it's like a wooden cup
it is no no the sippy cup but they got
all sorts of yeah they did they do the
what do they do with the straws paper
straws i don't know yeah i don't know
how they end up in the nose they suck
but they do something
after you ever see the third the spoon
from the basket robin's
the taster spoon the little the little
pink pink one yeah
i looked at myself in the mirror when i
put my underwear on and it looked like i
had a little spoon in my hand
i don't know how the [ __ ] what happened
to my dick
like skin doesn't just meat doesn't just
i mean
it's an atrophy yes but i mean if i work
that muscle you know not as you know i'm
more i'll work out more alone than what
there was
a group but
you know
it's funny when you get older like it
you you deteriorate you can [ __ ] hurt
yourself in your sleep you get up and
you would think that you would chase
somebody or you would be down in a
crouch position for you know a half an
hour
you know somewhere you you had to fit in
and then as you get older man you just
you it's crazy
i'm at the point in my life anything
happens pass out and they can't hold you
accountable for nothing hopefully they
won't [ __ ] shoot you after you're
down
back in the day back in my day
we didn't try to
resuscitate anybody we took their shoes
that's funny so crime
what do you make of uh of um how popular
you know documentaries have been on
crime
stuff yeah and and i think on podcasts
that's the number one thing is
yeah this is my my favorite murder is
like one of the biggest podcasts out
there
yeah exactly
i mean i don't i don't get it because i
you know i don't watch true crime at
home my wife does and i like hey you
know do i got to see this again you know
i'm tired of hearing those murder cases
and stuff like that i don't get it i
don't know i guess people love a good
mystery you know they love seeing
somebody else suffer and you know thank
you know there but for the grace of god
but also yeah but also um i was gonna
say uh every you know you can farm
yourself out as a as a professional you
know they come to you they go well the
thing is that you know we didn't know
that and they put your title under there
right those guys kind of
become accessories to
a fad right because
you can just hire a guy i'm sure they
all aren't the highest they're talking
we old enough did you know bill hagmeyer
from uh your agency he was uh back uh
behavioral sciences
yeah okay good friend and then
that's what i was talking to yesterday
out on the course oh
the i want to say it was oxygen is doing
something special doing a documentary on
the night stalker
i couldn't be involved in it
contractually i couldn't
and i knew bill [ __ ] contractually
this guy
the uh
bill had called me up because they asked
him to be a part and he was going to do
it now how your nickname would be excuse
me so you know if scott and i were in a
restaurant and they go like we're
[ __ ] contractually
there he is right there
that's how you get your nickname
just one you know like there's this dude
we call him kaka you know
we're like in our 30s and they go what
are you guys talking about it goes guess
who's getting married man he goes cool
hey man
and his wife is expecting baby wait a
minute they're gonna be little kakita
[Laughter]
right nickname is just you know how you
can call a guy whatever his nickname is
there's there's a trail back to it so
they're like contractually continuing
he was calling me he he ended up doing
it and he says god i wish you could i
said i can't and i said but you got the
best guy going you got bill hagmeyer
good friend he'll know
and
it's like
he asked me text me and i text him back
i said anything you want you know i'm
here yesterday when i was out on the
golf course with george he was calling
me getting ready to leave and do the
stuff i got a couple more questions you
know fill me in on this and so he gave
him this stuff
and uh in other words he was trying to
[ __ ] ride your coattail no no wait a
minute that's what that's that's what i
heard he can have anything well i told i
encourage him
contractually out there's your p.i firm
that's what i don't want to get on tv
and start talking about something i
don't know about well neither did bill
yeah do you think you've gotten do you
think your friends see you and go you
know if you're getting coffee in the
morning you look at you hear gil stocka
okay
yeah all right right because all of a
sudden now oh you can tell you could
everybody's it's like monday night
football everybody critiques every
player maker tricks every move the guy
you say that and just a little before i
came down here after talking to my wife
you know my name coming to call me you
thought about the uh
golf tourney yesterday i said and you
know what the realities are
if my friends the guys that i worked
with homicide if if they could hear me
talk they're saying you're a [ __ ]
puto you know
yeah they would you know what it'd be an
episode of the white shadow up here that
dude was still around yeah they laugh at
me
they think hey you ain't [ __ ] you
weren't [ __ ] then you're not [ __ ] now
you know these these are the hardcore
guys but did you guys watch streets of
san francisco growing up i didn't call
maldonado everybody did manix you
watched they watched all those shows
who's a good one uh joe forrester
remember joe farns oh yeah he said throw
the billy cup down a block down the
street yeah trip the guy hill street
blues
who could win uh uh joe forrester and
cup versus kung fu
i think joe phelps
oh [ __ ] annabelle
but but you see we see how far adam 12
uh dragnet was big like everybody was
watching dragnet
you know and not every police show
stayed
but she did san francisco was was big
the fbi fbi yeah was they they used
those real cases right it became almost
like what csi became yeah exactly yeah
and then they went you know then we went
reality and it was the untold stories of
the fbi and that that kind of thing
started that phase
but you know i just you know i'm with
gil i don't want to get up there and
start talking about somebody else's
cases and critiquing i'm going to like i
did the chippenhalls
document drama that's on now and i i you
know i'm going to talk about my case and
tell you what i did or the whitey bulger
case i'm not going to go and critique
gill's nightstalker investigation i
ain't going to do that right maybe i
know more than him that's respectful
yeah that's what law enforcement bill
was not i did this
he wasn't critiquing my he just wanted
information god i feel terrible i feel
terrible you know i i told him you know
this i think i would have been a good
interrogator i got you talking more
defending him
was there a sexual relationship involved
between you two
you're probably yeah at the fairfield
right here off the five freeway in
valencia you're going to take a little
pretty soon you got them using
contractions
case she was originally from pittsburgh
so i swore to bill i said we're going to
get the guy because she's from
pittsburgh just like you think
so
so he did right so they're still talking
about richard ramirez can't talk about
manson yeah sure forever
the whitey bulger still big in boston
people still talk about him in boston
i'm sure you know i i i i don't go back
there too often i'm a new york guy yeah
yankees fans uh you know oh yeah i got
low key when i go back there but yeah
i'm sure it's you know it is one of the
they always say oh he was the number two
after osama bin laden right but we don't
rank him that way so he was osama had
been killed in may of that year and then
we caught him in june so
but this is this is how different
that
crime has become
if you were a bad guy in the 70s 60s
they put your picture up in the post
office and that's really where
you would be in there in line buying
stamps and mailing and you'd look and
see wow i know that guy
i don't have a contraction i'm allowed
to speak about
but now
you don't even know who's on the top 10
list or you don't you know it doesn't
that kind of has gone it does and you
know when they did something like that
when he got somebody like that or
anything
people like myself get excited yeah you
know hey that's a good one that's badass
that's his case with that because i know
you're all part of the same team exactly
how much work how many man hours and how
much stress he went into doing this
it's it's awesome yeah
which is the best what about donnie
brosco is that a
and it was a it was a real it was a
great undercover operation he did in
five years he was under with the mob you
know a great movie and uh you know joe
piston i met him once briefly in a hotel
but yeah he's a great guy all around he
did and you you do kind of get absorbed
by
an undercover but you have to because
any any slip or anything that if you
haven't have you have an accent and you
don't use it
and i'm not kissing bill hagemeyer's ass
again with bill hagmeyer bill hagmeyer
said
the stone was one of the best partners
he ever had they were partnered up for a
while all right well why don't you say
that at first because i'll be higher on
the list
he's a good guy i'm telling him big lots
of security
driving around with the yellow light
a lot of people will [ __ ] just be
hanging around sorry sir i'm going to
call bill tell you better listen to this
podcast
they're going to find me dead like
marilyn monroe with a suppository in my
courtois
the remote control okay that means he
talked you're in mexico when they kill
somebody they do a sign like if they if
they cut your dick off and they and they
put in your mouth they go that guy you
know he was he talked his emphasis or
your thumb and your cool lotus you know
there's one for that he's a hitchhiker
shut the [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
but you know you know everybody has
their own you know system of evil
you know you've been in mexico
oh yeah i look around in mexico i i've
been to mexico i've i did that i did a
movie in mexico and and you see a uh
big truck police truck go by with the
big tires and a 50 caliber machine gun
on the back and seven guys on one side
and seven on the other all in black with
[ __ ] like this with the machine gun off
and you're just going that's just them
patrolling and you're just like oh yeah
we went uh
one of the trips i took tonight we would
bring back a couple of witnesses on a
case
and one of them was ready he was going
to pay on his own the following day
unbeknownst that we were going to be
down there
he was going to
get on his own and then pay a coyote to
bring him across wow
and we got there now hey he's free you
know we'll pay for we're paying for
everything
his partner that was out there really
didn't want to come back
he had been
a surviving gunshot victim
somebody else died now
and he really didn't want to come back
he was reluctant didn't say no i'm not
but when we got there to pick him up we
had guys from the houthi show the local
cops over there and they had
oozies with them
and this guy said well no i can't you
know i didn't say goodbye to my
grandmother and get him at his work
we already told your grandma you weren't
coming home yeah but i need to get some
clothes he says we got a sack of your
clothes right here
and
they're seeing again he says oh okay
so we went back to acapulco which was a
big
town
we were staying in and we told the i
told the commandant i said hey i need a
favor i'd put these guys up in the hotel
with us but one of them is a little
shady i'm afraid he'll
go back home
i said could you just not lock him up
but just entertain him
in your facility he says see
he put him he told call this guy down
hey take these guys up there to the
office put them up there do not lock
them up
he says when you get up there he says
then come on back i need to ask you for
another i need to give you another some
more instructions the guy comes on he
says okay look
those guys are not to be locked up but
they better not get away or it'll be you
do i understand we'll make myself clear
if they get away you'll pay
see me come on dante so they leave we i
tell them come on thank you we'd be by
in the morning pick them up
in the morning we go pick them up and
get them out and they're like daddy
you're here get us out of here so we
took him down got him in the airport
got him on the airplane
got him some drinks
and i'm saying well how was your stay
last night they take care of real
goodies oh it was ugly
he says the two guards were watching us
they started drinking they said [ __ ] it
lock those guys up man we can't let them
get away they'll kill us
so they put us in a cell with 12 other
guys and there were robbers there were
murderers in there he says and they're
looking at us pretty soon the guys
you know i want your belt i want your
wallet i want your watch i want your
shoes he said he took everything from us
he says the comandante got there in the
morning and he got pissed he said but
before he got there the two guards got
so drunk
they pulled out their guns they were
fighting to see who's going to get the
who's going to screw the the one broad
they had in custody they they wanted her
and they finally didn't do it they let
it go commandant gets there in the
morning
and he says what the [ __ ] are they doing
locked up he got pissed off got rid of
those guys he says come on took him out
to breakfast he says come on let's go
out and have breakfast took him out and
he says and he tried to calm us down he
said whatever you do please don't tell
carrillo please don't tell korea what's
happening
it's because at least everything went
well as well it's just that when we were
in there they stole our wallet our watch
our belt our jets the dead he says come
on back you see he went in he's got a
big piece of wood he said who got your
wallet he said that guy
bam bam start beating the [ __ ] up who
got your belt who got your shoes who got
your jewelry
and i said oh man i feel terrible i said
but the good thing is
at least you got everything back he says
everything except for my belt
and i said
why didn't you tell me how to get your
belt back he says the comandante like my
belt
well i was going to say if the cell
mates didn't get it the cops would have
gotten it yeah
wow yeah
that's the way it is then they can tell
i mean the mexicans can tell the mexican
americans oh yeah yeah oh that's right
too right because you guys are taught to
look at things and well they when we
chase them down there we bring them i
brought back dozens of people from
mexico and went down there and stuff and
they can tell you know they're so happy
you know you think they wouldn't be
happy coming back to the states to go
and face you know life in prison
whatever it is but they're very happy to
come back to the states are there so so
are there guys that are almost like you
know manipulators uh um
that know how to
you know because guys who are frauds
have to pretend to be different people
but criminals that you pick up that if
they start talking to you or talking to
a normal person then they get them to be
either accessories or help them you know
because there is a way to use the
language i guess and however
but if you're an fbi you're taught to
look for certain behavior like they
didn't hannibal lecter like a sentence a
lab they're like don't let that dude
talk to you because they'll get in your
head or even when women tell contrast
the birdman like they they would leave
his food
by the door and his bed was way back
over there they were like don't talk to
that [ __ ] guy because he'll he'll
spin you and yeah no no one's getting in
my head no one's getting a gill's head
either yeah yeah
there are guys like that well i'm sure
there's massive manipulators right yeah
you know the sociopaths
yeah i didn't do this you know i mean
meanwhile they got a video of him
stuffing a body in the into a 55 gallon
drop i didn't do it wasn't me you know a
lot of you you know like i'll tell you
the cold sky is not blue but um yeah i
mean i've been all over the world
bringing people back and
invariably everybody's happy to get back
to the united states even when they're
in locked up in jail you know with with
that brian laundry where the parents
went out maybe like
what do they protect him and his parents
protect him in any way can you can you
tell didn't they i mean supposedly
there's you know they're saying the
parents had nothing to do with it the
sisters saying that right but you got to
take that with a pound of salty yeah you
don't know what they did and what they
didn't do i'm sure the fbi knows they
can track them you know their movements
via cell phones and you know maybe
traffic cams and stuff like that
but you know it's it it's a 50 50 either
he went out and off himself or he's you
know living in a tent somewhere in the
everglades you know when that 911 call
came in and they said you know this guy
is slapping this girl and then they they
when they were done
with the whatever the comfort however
long the conversation was they were
willing to put the dude in the hotel and
let the girl
that's they're they're gonna they're
gonna crow after that because of
domestic violence laws the way they are
bad bad move and on their video on their
camera on their body but they both point
their fingers together he said that uh
you know he she attacked him and then
she i guess later on it came out that he
attacked her and somebody actually
witnessed him beating her up outside a
store in the main part of town so you'll
know better domestic violence cases we
never you know we don't work them fresh
somebody's got to go yeah somebody's got
to go and you lean towards whoever's got
the best story because you know the 911
call is clear it says this guy's
slapping and they're slapping the
officer's like what and then he pulls
him over
and then he the guy said she grabbed the
wheel that's why they hit the curb why
do you think they hit the curb because
of
because you grabbed the wheel did you
listen to the call i don't know i don't
know
you know she said she did he said she
did i don't know i would
more likely to believe um
well they both got marks on them so but
he's right somebody somebody's got to go
one of the two but you know i think in
social media and stuff like this where
people want to live the van life or
whatever it's [ __ ] dangerous out
there it's not easy to just live and
travel and post on instagram and not you
know come in contact with some people
that are
are not good people out there i wouldn't
be doing it in la that's for sure i'd be
you know maybe wyoming or utah i
wouldn't be coming down here in a van
life right too many vans on the street
already
it's changed so much here in los angeles
where people are you know a lot of
people move to arizona move to las vegas
but
you know uh leaving los angeles because
of the homeless
i mean i'm a native so i mean you are i
don't think i've seen
i've seen it this bad tennessee
tennessee is another big destination
right yeah
yep yeah yeah nashville and all that
yeah what what is the answer you think
to to to
the issue of homelessness in
in the united states mental health and
the majority i know i don't have an
answer
some things just need a whole lot of
leave alone you know yeah and wait until
they build a three-story thing out of
shopping carts across from your house
that's what they're talking about now
building a new multi-story place down in
downtown l.a for the homeless
i feel sorry for the homeless vets
you know uh
that that's really tough uh some of
those people are homeless had a choice
had a choice because now they're
addicted and their mind is gone and they
need mental health dope you know yeah
cocaine the brain has made them insane
you know
but
do veterans still live in the veterans
hospital or they still do that because
on sunday there was that party and we
drove down
on that street
in brentwood that runs along the va
hospital is guys living on the streets
outside well they just showed it on the
news the other day a bunch of guys a
bunch of pets all the flags are out
there they're living right across the
street
yeah from the beginning that's not that
can't be good that's how you could look
for him
that's i don't know i'm with gil i don't
what do you do it's mental illness how
do you force somebody to take drugs to
try and help them but we spent a lot of
time down there skid row just you know
and that's not
that's just the epicenter of it i mean
it's all over the city yeah that's good
bro yeah
skid row used to be it was confined to
that one area yeah
and
it's spreading out all over the city
county yeah
exactly and and again it brings crime
and it brings
you know people stealing packages off of
people's
uh porches and just taking bikes and
take breaking into cars and taking
whatever you know people shouldn't leave
that [ __ ] out there anyways but
you know it brings that makes the
quality of life crimes they call them
now yeah
you all right where do you live
i live in west hollywood all right
yeah he's in sheriff's territory he's
good so
so yeah
um
so so brian london you do you expect
because you know there's all then you
have people now you have foreign against
like they have like you know the people
that for him
are like oh the fbi they can't they
can't catch this guy
dog the bounty hunter will catch him
he's not walking down there now knock
the bunny bouncing will he catch him now
you know dawg uh he got his claim to
fame he scooped the fbi
back in i want to say early 2000 andrew
luster max factor guy max factor's
nephew a good journalist encyclopedia
the guy is a guy
yeah contradictory i can't talk about
porn
yeah but uh yeah that guy that's why he
scooped the fbi that's where he made his
made his bones and became uh you know a
celebrity after that and how did he find
him he got a tip yeah he got it yeah
because he's accepting tips you know
that's why i told him and he got well he
just like crime no but i mean what do
you know what really happened on that i
do we got a tip he got a tip the person
who took the tip i'm not going to say
what office was didn't uh maybe didn't
take it seriously enough and maybe
expedite the information so actually our
agents of mexico are in route to it was
port of vallarta right yeah
i think it was part of my art they were
out acting on a tip and dog acted on it
quickly got there and got him scooped up
and it was literally like minutes before
we got there and that's what happened so
it's just a matter of uh someone not
taking it seriously enough okay i'm not
as familiar
with the chippendales but i i have i
have seen uh uh
some stuff i was meant to i meant to
watch it but you know when you're
hungover
for about two days ago you started out
with chippendales i started out yeah i
did and then you know i couldn't keep it
on like my pants stopped monday
um but
let can you talk about that you talk
about crazy it's a crazy case and um
how how old were you gil when you got
involved with frank on the nightstarker
case
i was uh about 35 years old i'm sure you
weren't underage
can you contractually speak about that
let's just say i wasn't
i was a nubile i wasn't an adult
that's a poor that's one of my verses
from coming with me at 11 on friday
so i was like 31 k i just gotten in from
new orleans division transferred in put
me on a squad with a bunch of old timers
kind of like
similar to guild getting thrown with a
senior guy
and uh
they had just gotten a call and a guy
from vegas walks into the office says i
was hired to go kill some
uh dancers in england
okay well who hired you well this guy in
santa clarita all right so get him on
tape talking about it we go out long
story short we arrest the guy in santa
clarita he doesn't talk
about seven months later he hires an
attorney who finally is a friend of ours
a former prosecutor gets him to come in
and uh spill his guts
comes in says hey not only did i pay
this guy from vegas to go over and kill
uh some dancers which never happened
back in 87 i actually killed the
business partner of the owner
chippendales i remember all right and
then in 79 and they uh tried to burn
down uh the old club in santa monica
called the moodies which later became
the 3-2-1 and later became hooters
and then in uh 84 i tried to burn out a
red on you remember the red onion in the
80s how popular it
84 tried to burn down the red onion and
maria del rey that was the spot right
there that was it right and then oh by
the way 1990 before the uh the england
case i was trying to kill this doctor
and his 12 year old son
and it all had to do with greed and envy
and money and this owner of chip and
nails people leaving him to go start
competing businesses
the doctor allegedly screwed him over on
a new club in la
uh the the clubs the nightclubs in
marion del rey and the santa monica were
just competing nightclubs and he wanted
them eliminated and that's what it was
all about and his business partner they
had a dispute uh you know clubs were the
chippendales club in la was on overland
there was one in new york on 61st and
first and you know their clubs come and
go there's lots of problems with clubs
and uh but what he did is the owner of
chippendale's out here this guy steve
banninger he gave the touring rights
to his partner in new york named nick
denoy and as you know he took a tour
like that on the road every small town
usa bachelor parties bachelor
bachelorette parties and whatever
engagement parties
and uh you take it all over the world
and it was money was coming in hand over
fist
the guy out here the owner the guy who
started the club they didn't like that
so his solution let's get them killed
also prior to that he was declaring
bankruptcy he had published the calendar
the mail chip and nails calendar for
1987. he did 31 days for every month of
the night
that was like a million dollar hit
recall on those he wasn't letting black
black people in the clubs he was getting
sued uh tripping falls fire department
was closing down
but you know what because you can't let
you know you can't have dudes in the
audience with bigger dicks than the
dancers what am i watching this for
huh
you know what i mean you're like okay
thanks [ __ ]
let's get out of here just prepare a tab
and get the hell out of here by 10 pm
they used to fling the doors wide open
let the guys in right yeah and then the
girls were all horny and gold yeah they
were revved up
that's crazy remember that uh bachelor
probably bachelor party with tom hanks
oh yeah he's had the chip consultation
with the guy that come nick the dick and
he put the
the hot he put his
dick between a hot dog and the mom is
grabbing it
you know she's pulling it and then they
cut through and she's like dave she goes
i had a wang in my hand
that was good so so we had all this
information we just had a what we're
going to do with it right we had to
corroborate it and so that's what we i
mean this guy's locked up now how do you
know we got to get him out of jail
and now the owner of chippenhalls we
find out had been giving this guy money
for his lawyer fees or you know
eventually gave about a quarter of a
million dollars for hush money and be
quiet wow so he knew he was locked up
and um so it was a matter of getting him
out of jail and trying to figure out
you know getting his owner chip and that
was on tape admitting that he paid this
guy for the murder the murder for hire
the arsons and also that's what we did
we uh we you know freed him under a ruse
that he had a medical condition which
which he actually did but
put that out there and so um we sat on
our path of trying to get this guy on
tape
not very easy though wow he knew it he
knew he knew this guy was cooperating
but he didn't he wanted to be reassured
he wasn't so we had this one meeting in
santa monica in june of uh 92 at that
point
takes him into the men's room of the uh
hotel and has him stripped down his
skivvies looking for a recording device
and i had this italian tailor i knew i
had him so in a pocket in his shorts and
because we suspected he was going to
frisk him and luckily he didn't find it
but he still he won't even talk to him
even though we had a recorder he would
write notes on a sticky note hand it to
him he would write back and every time
he tried to talk our guy whoa so he
wouldn't talk to him so we knew we were
[ __ ] uh that was that man how about
that [ __ ] method there yeah
still paying the money though after that
meeting he gave him 40 000 an envelope
so um they did discuss that there the
owner said hey why don't you go over to
india because he was in india and i want
to go over there i'll set you up live
like a king in our informant and say hey
you [ __ ] kidding me you're gonna kill
me over there on the operating table you
know if i get a plastic surgery you'll
kill me
so eventually we came up with a ruse to
uh you know we made made a believe or
made it seem that our guy went on the
run become a fugitive got him a fake
passport got him a
you know a disguise
we put a warrant in the computer just in
case the owner would check with a cop
friend of his see if he actually became
a future that's what we did we go over
to italy and we and the plan was once we
get overseas
we're going to send the fax to the
chippendales and say we want to bring
the tour over to rome
so we get over there and a little detail
we forgot to plan for the guy was indian
he wasn't a citizen so he couldn't get
into italy without a visa and it was
going to take 30 days and we're there
sitting in [ __ ] room for two weeks
and we got to come up plan b because the
fbi is not going to like
guys and sitting on a government dollar
for 30 more days so sure he the owner
said hey i'm going to be in geneva i can
drive over to zurich and meet you oh
[ __ ] i'm going to be able to do this
and uh i said okay we'll get back to you
tomorrow got to the office the next day
we started sending faxes and emails all
over back to headquarters and back to
zurich
zurich said the police said come on up
and we'll help you guys out
and we did hopped on a plane and got up
to zurich switzerland
and uh met with a great bunch of cops i
mean these guys you know we brought our
recording equipment in there they looked
at it and they kind of thumb to get the
stuff out of it
we got swiss watches here right we're
not going to use your cheap american
recording equipment they wired up this
hotel room and so we make a call the
owner chippenhalls we've got a
surveillance team coming in in the
airport from geneva
now he goes to the ramada renaissance
our guy calls him at a prearranged time
says he says come over to my hotel room
now i'm not going to go let's meet the
hilton [ __ ] now we got to go to another
hotel right now wire up his jacket
that's smart man huh yeah this guy's
crafty right but still right he knew the
guy in his heart of hearts he knew the
guy was cooperating but he wanted to be
reassured that he wasn't ratting him uh
writing him out to the fbi
and uh he goes over the restaurant they
meet in the cafe and what's the first
thing our informant does we got the
microphone in his jacket he takes his
jacket off
he puts it on the bench next to him i
saw [ __ ] i'm listening on the
transmitter in the car with my swiss
partner right i got to do something i go
in there to lobby the hotel i get my
overcoat it's cold and take it on take
it off take it on take it off three
times in front of the uh the doorway
hoping our guy would see us he didn't
see it but swiss cops said leave it up
to us they go in they close the
restaurant down they tell them to d uh
you guys are closed now to get everybody
out
and they did they got everything
yeah he put his jacket on but he doesn't
come back to the hotel he goes to the
bar and i imagine doing a recording in a
bar the piano guy's playing the glasses
are clinking people are drinking the
bartender so we still have a we're
getting some bits tidbits i'm still not
getting enough after about two hours in
the bar they finally go back to the
hotel room and they just it was like a
recording studio the way these switch
was
as clear as this podcast i'm sure wow
man and it's talked about everything and
the owner said the chip now says do they
know i gave you the money for the guns
do they know i gave you the money for
the he called it the d because it was
the guy's name was denoia and we got
everything got everything on tape clear
as a bell
go back to this you know we don't arrest
them right because we have to do grand
jury get an indictment we have to make
believe our guy is still on the run as a
fugitive so we have to go back to the
states hide him out and we do an
indictment we go pick him up and uh the
owner chip and i was arrested in
september of 93.
arrest him outside chippenhal's the
business offices and he says
this is [ __ ] i'll beat this case i
got good lawyers wow a year later he
pleads guilty to rico racketeering right
right the rico law is the one we use
against the mob and we charged him as
using his business like the mob would
arson murder for hire murder that's rico
that's rico and you're able to seize the
business so the government was in line
this forfeit chip and nails and we would
have owned it
what does he do the day of his
sentencing he hangs himself in his jail
cell downtown l.a
and so because he didn't go in that day
to court and get a sentence he played
this 26 years that was a plea bargain uh
when you're not sentenced you're not
convicted and when you're not convicted
there's no forfeiture so we got [ __ ]
wow man did that guy he knew what he was
doing he knew what he was doing yeah so
like i went to his family basically he
went to yeah he went to his family
eventually the wife got everything i
think edward hernandez did that kind of
yeah
that epstein allegedly did that right
yeah jeffrey epstein so uh yeah it's not
surprising that's uh that's what i kind
of i kind of feel that's what laundry
did brian laundry you know just a circle
back i meant i kind of feel that's what
he did you know maybe killed himself
because the future's not good for him he
knows it he knows he knows and he's not
i mean he's a sociopath in a sense right
but he's still a young man whatever what
his life would be but right i think you
kind of
write your own pain in your own picture
that the future's not gonna be good for
him probably easier yeah especially when
you get to prison right guys that kill
women they don't fare as well right as
maybe a gangster shot another homeboy or
something like that but
as we know but yeah so that was the chip
in hills case in a nutshell but the
other part of it we had we had the
actual hitman the guy did the murder in
new york in 87. it was an nypd
investigation and
that guy turned out he was locked up out
in norco on a narco charge and we had to
figure out how to get our guy into
prison with a wire on without you know
ever try to do anything in prison you
can't keep anything a secret right so we
tried we had to do that it took us three
times
uh to get him on tape admitting that he
actually pulled the trigger and killed a
guy in new york in 87. first time there
was a problem in the prison and so there
was a lock down and the tape recording
is running it's by time he gets in the
tapes out
second time
that gets worse
this was not this is the craziest part
of the podcast to me it was just
the second time
uh
our informant
we got our informant was somebody uh
somewhere along the lines of you
remember joe pesci and lethal weapon
kind of like you want to be want to be
with the guys hey guys i want to be one
of the guys but he was you know he's a
criminal right and we had to keep him
with us he was supposed to be under our
custody and our protection but we want
to get rid of him you know
but he's that kind of guy so he meant
well but he wasn't the brightest
so we wire him up here in westwood at
the fbi office we got a about a two-hour
drive out to norco and traffic what does
he do he turns the recording device in
the car records a whole conversation
on the way from westwood to norco anyway
by time he gets into the jail cell onto
the the jail courtyard prison courtyard
he thinks he's turning it on he turns it
off so we don't hear any of the
conversation
so he's got like a full confession in
that one basically yeah because you were
listening
got a full confession and so and that's
that was early december december of 90th
i think that was 93 at the time or 92.
uh and then um
we i listened to tape and there's
nothing on there so my partner i went up
there we said what the [ __ ] are you
doing are you trying to sabotage this
investigation what are you doing you
shut the thing off we heard our whole
conversation you calling the prosecutor
i see you next tuesday you going after
the judge
what did you do
you put our ass in a bind here i'm sorry
guys i'm 100 with you guys i'll do my
best
so now we got to get him into the prison
again so christmas eve it's 92 christmas
eve of 92 he gets in the third time to
see this guy louie rivera gilberto lopez
rivera
so he gets we called him louie he gets
him in and finally
i got two recording devices on them i
got a transmitter on them i'm not going
to blow this one
and they have this one crucial part of
the conversation where louis tells our
informants yep i walked into the room i
asked him if you're a nick denoya he
stood up he had a smile on his face i
pulled my gun out smile went away and
then next thing i see is the red dot in
the form goes what do you mean the red
dot he goes where the bullet went in his
face
and that's all we needed and that was it
wow kitching
that's nice it's beautiful yeah
you know yeah there's nothing nothing
even at the highest level like nothing's
ever reliable i never you know i never
heard a story where the guy took his
jacket off then he hits the thing he
records that like that's late plans man
they always go best laid plans and and
then the problem was this guy lopez the
ruse we used to get him to talk about a
murder five years before we told him how
to go back and kill
the witness in the office there was a
witness in the front of the office that
was like joining offices and he said he
had to go back and kill that guy
our guy's getting out of norco prison
like two months later expecting another
25 thousand dollars go kill somebody
else we had to do something with him get
him on ice because we didn't have the
owner locked up yet
so he luckily he was in uh it wasn't
legal legally here in the united states
he had been previously deported uh
several times so he got ice to lock him
up yeah and on a five-year charge we
kept him good nypd went down eventually
got him uh confessing to the murder but
he still went to trial even though he
confessed got him on tape confessed nypd
he still took it to trial in new york a
couple a couple of years later
guilty
do you imagine that you know like bugsy
siegel had this vision for las vegas you
know then he got shot through his eyes
because he was over budget yeah
yeah maybe uh intentionally or
unintentionally right right
and i just don't think you know he had
his girl there and his [ __ ] girl was
crazy and he's trying to do the
contractors are charging him double he
doesn't know what the [ __ ]
you know things cost
and you know he gets taken out over them
beverly hills you know pictures of him
there and then you see what you know
vegas has become he's become because of
him yeah well and that's what
chippenham's become right a cultural
phenomenon right there's been lots of uh
uh imitators right thunder from down
under there was one it's all derived
from chippenham and supposedly this is
what not many people know
as the legend goes the idea came from
paul snyder and dorothy stratton that's
right right from star 80 star 80 right
the playboy playmate of the year in 1980
dorothy stratton her
sicko boyfriend paul schneider crazy
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
supposedly he they're canadian and
supposedly he saw this male strip tease
act in canada right goes to chip and
nail says hey you ought to try this
because they were doing like they were
doing like mud wrestling backgammon at
the car yeah they were doing all this
kind of stuff and and just they tried it
they tried and it was you know it was um
it was kind of a lewd and body and it
wasn't real it wasn't a show to it was
just guys coming out taking their
clothes off women waving dollar bills
and come kiss them on the lips for a
buck right and there's this guy deny it
that denooyer was married to uh in the
past jennifer o'neill remember from
summer 42
these guys didn't know and i said
jennifer o'neal and uh we were i think
we were on the road and funny you say
that
that was if you're out there jennifer
gorgeous woman everybody one eight five
three two
so yeah so nick was married to her one
emmy so he came in he made he made the
show he transformed it something
you know women like a story right so the
guys would come in they'd be the perfect
man like frankenstein would be created
right yeah sure women love that stuff
and uh choreography and good music and
he transformed and it became
but they were you know the the indian
guy here banished he was envious because
he was getting all the attention as
being the creator of chippendales i mean
he did on saturday night live patrick
swayze
and chris farley was awesome i was just
looking up the data that was in 1990.
what was that 1990 1990 midst of all
that yeah and that dude so paul snyder i
think did he realize that he was onto
something there but because he was he
was sleazy he was yeah i got a [ __ ]
fur coat to the playboy mansion with
some big medallion and camel toe and
[ __ ]
with his pants tucked in his boots like
you killed the first time
right now i see him but it's like when
you got out
you know
he dropped his keys try to [ __ ] hide
i saw the cane roll up on the car that
hey i see your cane
when you see somebody dipping i was uh
we should you know
like being undercover so there's this
guy
at an alleged golf course i don't like
the guy i don't like a lot of tokyo i
didn't join
a golf course to be friends with the
members like i just want to play golf
first of all i don't look i look more
like the staff than i look like the the
members
and uh i would run into this dude the
other landscaper and so i'm running this
dude we're filming at the odyssey in
mission hills where i used to we used to
go out there and we're filming in there
and then we're filming in the one part
of the restaurant up below there's a bar
overlooking you know the valley and i go
down there and this dude has a martini
with this woman and they're just as
they're tipping they go like this [ __ ]
going all over his head and he's like
[ __ ] because that's not his wife
and i was like he saw me man the [ __ ]
just
you know you see that when the blood
runs out of somebody's face you're just
like what's up
[ __ ] is he that was the last person that
i want to see i didn't write him out i
think he ratted himself out i think he
felt
that i would but i'm not right i don't
care if i don't like the guy but i think
he's a stand-up guy i
what's the matter you're not a rat but
yet you told the story about when i got
out of the car and my half into my booth
you know the style that bingo's the one
oj used to you know
run to the airport with
but you know but that uh um
all of that stuff man is i think fast
more fascinating if you see what the
documentaries become
um versus um
you know the shows that we do squid
games is like number one everywhere that
is korean i mean we can't
you know i just mesmerized right now
listening to him tell the story because
i know it's real yep and i know it's
from a real cop nobody's making it up
it's from scott that i've worked with
that i know
and i was just sitting here 30 years ago
that's what i can't get over it's 30
years ago people still want to talk
about this story 91 is when we september
91 is when i actually started it
and you know and then all of a sudden
nightline is doing that 2020 is gonna be
on friday i don't know when you're
airing but 2020 is going to be on friday
night a whole two hours on this case and
it's on discovery plus now it's like
okay
and then what's the fascination of it
because it's exotic dancers and i think
it's because you you have this yeah you
have this image of chippendales and you
know lighthearted and fun and you know
going to there for your bachelorette
party whatever and then behind it under
the surface is all this you know
murder and this you know scheming and
you know double crossing and you know
it's just great
i watched the new fbi show the the new
one on there and there you go hold on i
didn't stop putting your hair like my
advisor i'm just looking at your hair
you looked through the technical
advisory technical advisor was scott
curiola
and when i saw i said well [ __ ] i want
to watch this whole thing because see
when i'd see scott it's in the office
never saw him and he played hey come
here and give me here's all the work
right you know that's right
so i don't know how many people he had
working behind him at what office out of
a car out of a bar whatever he was doing
and i watched this show the other day
now did you have that many people
working for you
hell no yeah well though you know we had
when i knew you we had two sheriff's
deputies two lapd and myself and that
was our team and that's what we you know
it was non-stop you know never you know
i i arrest guilty i remember you had the
case you had it was a really good case
it was the murder of the 7-eleven clerk
uh duarte dougherty monrovia
monroe duarte
why was that one because you know
there's murders everywhere but it was
just you know innocent 7-eleven
syed hussein
yeah wow
i remember the family
i kept i still every once while i get a
touch from one of the brothers
in minnesota i think all right we call
one guy here but um
and there was thousands of those cases
right that was but that one i remember
specifically uh
you know
it's easier to remember those cases then
because they're let's go kill pookie
right right two gang members or the
blood and the crips or whatever going
after somebody it's easy to remember
this one
i think i think potentially
we don't want to watch this one but i
think in in in this one i think that the
wonderland murders i don't think there's
been a donkey series on on that
you know john holmes and the guy eddie
nash and that nightclub i remember that
when he went in there and left the
sliding i mean open lower canyon
sliding did the movie yeah he left the
sliding glass he's going there yep he
was he was all coked out they had aids
john holmes
and when they left the sliding
glass door open and then they went in
there and just
pushed everybody to everybody and i
think i think maybe
if you look at the reality of what um
i made from
you look at succession or you look at
billions i mean people are fascinated by
that but nothing is as fascinating as
even listening to someone talk about
real crime as opposed to sitting there
and watching a showtime version of
uh embezzling
it's not as much as watching bernie
madoff or or watching you know stuff on
whitey bulger
you know although black mass was pretty
good
they cut my part out at the end the
arrest the whole arrest scene oh they
cut it out
were you in there do you have a cameo or
just you they cast somebody to play me
of course italian guy when he walked
down
that's how they got in the parking lot
right there in santa monica we got we
got it we roosed them down in the
parking lot
otherwise and luckily we did
because
well
you know if you want to be in the whole
story but yeah we so we get to tip that
day
that day that day one of his neighbors
right was it was it was it was a person
yeah who yeah i'm sorry
i'll be cautious i'm sorry
i just got something i got someone
killed your mother detail was never
revealed
he said he wasn't a rat yeah
hi this is scott again could you edit
that so now there's two things can you
make my introduction just you know
just under five minutes
and then can we just eliminate that
other part they got the word
contractually
yeah because he
you know those guys
you live under the i mean way under 16
years under the radar crazy he was yeah
took off from boston with one woman
circles the united states with her right
she gets tired she's got four kids back
in boston goes back drops her off does
like an exchange picks up his other
girlfriend catherine greg and takes off
with her winds up in santa monica on
third in washington santa monica i had
lived a block away when i was in school
damn
right so it's kind of crazy so that day
i'm off i got three kids i'm home the
week you know school ends summer camp's
not starting yet i'm off with three
friggin kids at home driving me crazy
and luckily i got a call from boston say
hey we just got a tip we did this public
service announcement and uh we got a we
think it's a good tip on where whitey is
now you know what i remember that public
service announcement you do i do 30
seconds it would have his picture and it
would say this is what we're looking
right here if it's voiceover with just
the the voiceover but they had her on it
the key was they put her picture on it
they had plastic surgery pictures of her
that they had pre like really close high
def oh wow okay prior to plastic surgery
and really close-ups on her face
i think i've got it here if you guys
want to hear it let's see
yeah
yours is the third one up gil
36 should be 30 seconds i got the
security footage i know you went in to
try to get that camera
have you seen this woman the fbi is
offering one hundred thousand dollars
for tips leading to catherine grieg's
whereabouts these photos are from the
early 1990s greek has had plastic
surgeries
we need the headphones we need the
headphones
here just throw those back on the table
and we can what's that turn yours up and
then yeah it is on there but okay now
turn the headphones up
all right
you know you're efficient up until
oh there it
has had is surgeries she is wanted for
harboring james whitey bulger a fugitive
on the fbi's 10 most wanted here it is
yeah 60 year old greek is the girlfriend
of 81 year old bulger he has a violent
temper and is charged with 19 murders
[Applause]
i think
did he ever work do you think he were
after 16 years i think you think
you critique every you know people get
sloppy sometimes i'll i'll go down and
get it or some [ __ ] like that
like she changed her face but that did
it right yeah that that's what
and let you know
how many how many people may have saw
that right over the uh 14 markets and
then it was broadcast by cnn all over
the world wow and we got one call a call
came in there's a call came into la
she and she didn't feel satisfied with
the response she got she called
headquarters dc
she didn't feel satisfied with their
response and she called boston so the
next morning on june 22nd 2011
boston calls me i'm at dick's sporting
to do my three kids trying to keep me
occupied
and actually i got an email and i'm
reading it's oh we got a hot lead need
somebody to roll out on a cover of
whitey bulger lead now this is 2011. i
had worked plenty of fugitive leads on
them i worked organized crime cases i
covered plenty of fugitive leads on them
back then i said this is [ __ ] i'm
not [ __ ] going to go out again and
i've got three kids you know what am i
going to do i'm going to get a
babysitter and then you'll test this you
get this feeling in your stomach that
hey this is you know something's good
with this one right
and
i i was responding i deleted my email
said just call me they called me they
told me about the psa public service
announcement and this woman i call said
she's you know sure it's him
got the kids back home got the
mother-in-law i sent a text i had four
lapd guys working with me that day i
said i've got to roll to santa monica
got a hot lead on whitey bulger the
texts come back who's whitey bulger
michael hey you see do you see jack
nicholson in the departed okay he's
based on that character right okay meet
me down there
so on the way down i'm trying to you
know on the phone calling all my sources
trying to you know check everything i
got we have the name charlie and carol
gasco
but i'm trying to you know
get a background of these people can't
find anything on them i'm thinking i
kind of grew up in santa monica when i
came out for school i'm saying okay you
know back in the 80s there was a huge
immigration of russian jews when the
wall went down and santa monica you know
so maybe that's the you know they don't
have a real uh background to them
because they're immigrants that's okay
i'll go for that nothing would come up
on them we get down there we set up on
the place
i go in
turns out the apartment complex and
there's a hotel across the street a
little boutique hotel and owned by the
same people so i go into the hotel look
for the manager
he's off that day
so uh
i get him on the phone he goes hey man
i'm off today i said hey i was off today
too
[Laughter]
i said i said
you're right across the street just come
over to the hotel i want to talk to you
so eventually he comes over i got a
couple of pictures i cover the uh the
wanted thing on the top right just slide
him to pictures and immediately puts he
drops his head into his hands and starts
shaking his head like this and said
i know those people ugly yeah who are
they that's charlie and carol gasco i go
those are my next door neighbors
i go these people your next-door
neighbor how only been your neighbors
for it was about five years
i go okay i go let's whitey bulger and
catherine greg white he's you know one
of the most wanted men if not the most
modern man in america at this point
and he goes well you know i know uh
whitey bulger is i said you know who
mighty bulger is he goes well i lived in
boston for five years
i said well let me get this straight you
lived in boston for five years and you
lived next door these people fought five
years and you never put two and two
together he was i never saw a picture of
him until now i said all right i said
well
you know there's a two million dollar
reward on his head
and wait a minute i think it's all
coming all right well i said
i said but obviously somebody led us
right to the doorstep here i said you
know if what you're saying is true and
it's them there's still a hundred
thousand dollar on her head she's wanted
for aiding and abetting and harboring a
fugitive i said you know we may have
some leeway with that
he goes okay let's go down and talk in
the basement so we go down talking about
i get a little worried at that point
right i think maybe this is some kind of
trip wire they call it right sure
whitey's paid this guy to you know take
me out in the basement if they ever come
looking for it we go down there and tell
them hey this is what i need i need x y
and z and uh you know i need a key to
the place oh you know
i need a subpoena i need a search
warrant i said how about a hundred
thousand dollars
story change right okay what do you need
i said well let's go over i want to see
uh what we can do to get him out of the
place when's the last time you saw him i
haven't seen him in two weeks
i'm worried now right because maybe he
saw the psa and took off right so we
were able to get a room in a hotel same
floor third floor as their apartment i
put a guy up in there i had three guys
just covering the exterior i said let's
go over i want to see uh before i try a
roof so what rouge do you want to try i
think i got a whole bunch of ruses that
won't work this won't work that won't
work i said let's go over the uh the
garage next door and the building we go
over there and i see these uh
uh storage lockers above these carport
areas yeah i have one of those yeah yeah
remember in santa monica used to have
them you have a combination lock on it
yeah and a little space for you numbered
i said does he have one goes yeah he has
this one over here i went over and look
the name gasco was on it as this we're
going to do i'm going to cut the lock
i'm going to take some [ __ ] out of there
throw it on the floor you're going to go
back you're going to call them and we're
going to get them to come down you tell
them we're going to call the police if
something's missing but nothing's
missing then i'm not going to call the
police i figured they wouldn't want the
cops called right and what the future is
going to want to have to show you by the
cops
so he goes okay he says i'll go back
over you know i went upstairs with him
to his apartment turned out to live
right next door to each other the
manager and uh whitey and i went i
tried to figure everything i could to
see if i could hear any noise coming out
of their voices i put the old glass to
the wall
you know those buildings are a plaster
you can't hear [ __ ]
so um i said go back to the office i
called my office in westwood i said hey
uh i need some you know some backup here
just send me three people i'm stay a
block away i took my three lapd guys put
them in the car in the garage i got my
car in the garage we had the one guy
looking
from his observation post and he's hey i
see the female the female just came out
to the balcony it's a pretty good look
for her now i'm feeling good right
boston's texting me what's going on
what's going on i said hey
let me handle it and see what happens so
this is about we got down there about 12
o'clock that afternoon this is about six
o'clock
so we're waiting in the basement uh i
called the manager and i say make the
phone call tell them uh you know tell
them your storage lock was burglarized
makes the phone call calls me back said
there's no answer and i said okay i said
well uh plan b go knock on the door and
tell them you're the manager right
that's what a manager would do he goes
i'm not gonna do that i go why not he
goes i just googled him he killed 19
[Laughter]
just go just hang tight let me think of
plan b
so uh i tell my guys on the radio hey
you know sit tight for a little bit
gotta come up to plan b and before i
could do that he calls me back so all
right he's on his way down
and uh he said i just spoke to the wife
she's sending him down
sure enough you hear the elevator coming
from the third floor coming down to the
basement and
i'm looking at my rear view i see this
old timer come out he's got the hat on
nice crisp jeans white white his shirt
goes in makes the right turn goes to the
storage locker puts his hands on his
hips are shaking it and we just bum
rushed him
and the [ __ ] just like he barely put
his hands up and he started taking a
couple of bunny hops to the right and
you know
immediately is this guy running on me 81
years old he's running on me and he
finally he wouldn't get down on his
knees because of the oil and the parking
spots in the garage right so he finally
got down
i said uh what's your name because you
identify yourself like all right i can
hear the accent now the boss had
actually
a mistake unmistakable boston accent
right i said i'm scott garriola with the
fbi and i got a warrant for your arrest
he goes okay
i go you don't want to tell me your name
he goes no you know who i am
simultaneously this woman starts
in the garage starts getting my
attention come on over come on over she
tells me he's got alzheimer's i go what
got that guy there he's charlie gaskell
he's got alzheimer's
my [ __ ] heart just sunk into my
stomach i'm thinking now i just arrested
an 81 year old guy who may have
alzheimer's or dementia or something
like that so i go to them i say hey
listen uh will you tell me who your name
is the woman over there says you have
alzheimer's
he starts screaming [ __ ] that woman
she's a [ __ ] nut you guys are crazy
i'm james j bulger
all right that's what i
no decency no uh discretion just starts
screaming at the woman in the 15 feet
away so i said hey is katherine upstairs
i knew she was right catherine upstairs
he goes yeah you know i got any weapons
in the apartment he goes yeah and
they're all loaded
i said are you telling me i gotta get a
swat team to get catherine out he goes
no no no give me the phone i'll call her
uh all the guns are in my room and she's
never held a gun in her hand alcohol
should come down i said i can't do that
i said give me the keys i'll go up i'll
treat her like a gentleman i'll get her
out
this time i grabbed one of the female
agents that had responded from our
office her and another guy we went up
knocked on the door covered the people
santa monica police ma'am
she opens the door and all she said was
i knew it and that was it put handcuffs
on her
uh you know dragged him downstairs and i
asked her for consent to search the
place she said what did he say i said
well let's go find out
take him down there and um i said hey
guys uh you know
i'd like to search your place
you tell me there's a bunch of weapons
in there you know uh you guys give me
consent
he looked at her he goes they're going
to get it anyway might as well go yeah
so i took his handcuffs off i gave one
we have a consent to search for him
all right he signs his name james j
bulger and he looks at me because the
first time i've signed that name in a
long time so i had i had both of them
signed the name uh because you know
nobody actually controlled the apartment
they both were
they weren't no lease i say you both
signed it for me they both signed it and
uh i said okay well tell me what's up
there
oh i got uh about 500 000 under the bed
i got weapons i pulled this book out
there's a fake book with a 22 in there i
said whoa whoa whoa
i said okay there's a lot in there take
you take me upstairs and show me he goes
yeah he went upstairs and he said take
that mirror down in a little bar there's
gonna be a bunch of weapons in there
there's gonna be money in there take
this bag underneath there's gonna be
money in there that book is two uh 357s
over there
all total we found about 823 000 cash in
the walls and we found 33 weapons and a
bunch of them were loaded and i asked
him i say why do you say what's with the
loaded weapons decision are you going to
shoot it out with us who would have came
through the door to get you
he kind of paused for a bit and he said
you know he said i think a stray bullet
would have hit somebody i'm assuming
meaning catherine
uh so would you have fought with us he
goes yeah i would have fought with you
on the streets and said i didn't carry a
weapon outside i would have fought my
fist he was a he was a tough son of a
[ __ ] at 81. let me tell you he had a
boxing dummy in the corner of his room
right he was he was fit he was fitted he
won 10 years earlier i think he would
have been you know giving us a hell of a
run but yeah he's good fun you know
typical old mobster style you know quick
with the jokes you know
she was just kind of you know submissive
and demure to him and uh
and and that was that's how we got him
and took him to court got in there the
next day and then you know by the time i
got out of the apartment
uh you could imagine the streets were
closed off you know hundreds of media
people out there
santa monica had to close off two or
three streets it was crazy so
you know a good little good little hook
and went back i testified at the trial i
had to bring all the evidence back to
boston obviously testifies the last
witness for the government
and he winds up he gets you know got
convicted i think he got convicted of
maybe 17 of the 19 murderers and
you know he got i don't know how many
life sentences he got and
you know the epilogue is that a few
years ago
they transferred him from like it's
transferred from arizona to florida
because he starts doing some corrupting
of a prison staff member in arizona
getting letters to catherine who was
also locked up around the normal prison
uh prison rules right transfer to
florida he goes to florida threatens a
staff member you don't do that in bureau
of prison so they transfer them to a
higher level security he goes to a
prison in west virginia
and he gets there that night next
morning he's beaten to death in his uh
his prison cell
with a
sock with a bunch of uh rocks or
something in there coins metal
what was that
padlock in there oh wow
i was talking about your padlocks and
you know they still got a guy from what
i heard they still got a guy locked up
in solitary and that was
three years ago maybe
i don't remember when it was three years
ago
and four year three pm so do you think
he knew that what happened to him i
think jeffrey dahmer knew that was gonna
happen you know i don't know i mean
you know he's got to figure he's a
legend but the problem was the guy that
alleged to have beaten him
was a genovese associate not from boston
but from springfield mass right so same
same state same you know different mafia
family but he's alleged the one who'd
done it and supposedly he didn't like
rats and you know whitey had the jacket
on for being a rat after we testified
in the trial they you know they exposed
him as he had a huge informant file with
the fbi and that's another whole part of
the story right his handling agent the
supervisor
both were accused of uh
you know
giving him confidential information in
exchange for information on the mafia
they let whitey do his stuff with his
winter hill gang the irish mob in
exchange for taking down the italian mob
that's you know the allegations
against the fbi annette
but it was 16 years of you know that
problem the fbi faced when everything
came out about corrupt fbi agents so
they had to rebuild their relationship
up there but
yeah but he got you know in the end i
guess he got you know got to what he
deserved he was 90
i think he was almost 91 by that time
because it was
90 90 years old probably
by the time he died catherine just got
out catherine got out a couple of years
ago so she's free she got seven or eight
years
uh for harboring aiding and abetting
so 89 he passed at 89. he was 89 years
old okay almost 90. but you know without
threatening that agent he would have
stayed in arizona i think the further he
got got to florida it's a little bit
dangerous and then you go to west
virginia so by his own hand you know
he's
west virginia was like a penitentiary so
that's where you know yeah i worked up
at the penitentiary here in lompoc on
some cases and that's you know
it's just like being in pelican bay or
uh san quentin you know it's rough is it
is it uh
you've been in the metropolitan where
where epstein was i think this is that
where el chapo was for a while oh i knew
that was in new york city mcc
where i've seen himself we're [ __ ] on
uh chapel's like hey man this prison is
[ __ ] awful yeah like get me out of
here
it's damp and rodents and [ __ ] it's like
a [ __ ] dungeon down there yeah the
mcc metropolitan correctional center
everybody that goes in there and that's
a you know chopper he's through his
attorneys like i gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here well it's like the guys i tell
you i bring back from mexico or wherever
i bring them back from istanbul's like
thank god you came and got me i'm tired
of living in a hell hole yeah yeah
and choppa with his money he had it made
in mexico that's why he didn't want to
come over here yeah yeah that's right
because they still let them operate
and do that stuff but
you think whitey bulger you know they
stayed there for that did anybody
believe that that the hotel manager
didn't
didn't know
i was like you know
you knew him from boston and then
and then i i don't i don't think he knew
i don't think he'll be turning your
little tricks over there
we've got more than five minutes we're
gonna come and get you
i don't think the manager knew uh
honestly i didn't yeah i think he was
you know because when you're a manager
you're maybe you're the night time
you're not you don't you're not you know
you're dealing with people every day you
know what gave me your thoughts what
gave him away was he kept on passing
himself off from chicago and anybody
who's been traveled a little bit can
tell the difference in chicago accident
and in boston yeah that boston accent is
unmistakable so the person who ended up
calling us said you know there was a
couple of clues one was they met each
other over a stray cat and that was kind
of the thing with catherine and him they
loved animals right they had these two
standard poodles that they were crazy in
love with and some of the leads we
covered looking for him was going to the
pet shops and groomers that was one of
the things the other thing was the
accident he claimed he's from chicago
but he sounds like he's from boston and
the third thing was he was a freaking
racist man he was all over ant it was
during obama's terms obama sucks blacks
this and so racist so that was another
thing because he was involved heavily in
the 70s with the anti-busing riots in
boston right so all these things when
you know the person called in it was
like hey you know this makes sense well
that makes sense and this makes sense
and you know
so and that's why when i finally heard
the story i said hi come and get me i'll
get a babysitter you know yeah send me
the lead so you knew you like you guys
said you get that feeling that this is
something you get a hunch yeah you get
the hunch and you know it happens once
in a while hey maybe go let's go to this
place instead of that place and
you know
it works out something and he wasn't
like you [ __ ] god you know he
was in the beginning he was like [ __ ]
you guys you know [ __ ] you
identify yourself you know and then once
i brought up catherine the girlfriend
and i you know asked if she was upstairs
and i need a swat team to get her you
know he what he said was you know
everything i do i'll cooperate with you
guys everything i do i want to go to her
benefit he knew he was [ __ ] he didn't
get away after in charge of 19 murders
he wanted everything to quit i said
listen i can't promise you anything i'm
not the judge or the prosecutor what i
can do is i can let them know that you
were very cooperative with me you signed
a consent to search you went up there
you point out all the weapons were you
even told me about an inert grenade that
was in the wall
you know so we didn't have to worry
about that
the 33 weapons you told me which ones
were loaded you told me all the money
was all the fake ids that he had and it
turned out what he was doing he was
going to the santa monica bluffs where a
lot of transients and homeless live and
he was finding someone that looked like
him and he would just co-opt them and
you know buy their life buy their
identity he'd buy people's driver's
license social security cards military
discharge papers and then he would you
know befriend him wow and smart
and one guy
we knew two guys specifically one guy
had uh he told us that he drank himself
to death in a uh
kind of like a flop house by the uh our
office in westwood and so he said once i
found out that guy died he i went over i
was using this car i dumped the car off
wiped all the prints down dumped a
bottle of vodka all around the car left
the keys and i had a bank account open
his name i never touched it again right
because he knew the guy was dead he was
smart then i went and found another guy
that looked like him and he went to find
this other guy so now this other guy is
alive and boston says to me they said we
want you to go find that guy and go
interview him and then give him a
subpoena come come back to boston and
testify in a grand jury
i said all right but he's going to be
probably a transient so that i get an
address on him figure out where he is in
the valley i go out there i knock on his
door it's like these little one-room
flop houses you know two stories knock
on the door
no answer i'm banging on the door it's
like nine o'clock in the morning banging
on the door and finally people coming
out hey you we saw him about three
o'clock in the morning uh last time we
saw him i said all right let me go
around the back i come up the uh the
dirt path and i look in the window and
he's on the floor passed out right look
at this i got to get this guy on a plane
to boston to testify
i go back around i opened the door and i
said hey mr terry wake up mr terry wake
up i get down i need to start hitting
him on the he was kind of cold
kind of cold
moved his head
stuff had come out of his mouth this
guy's dead
the guy either he was the guy he either
was you know
coincidentally drank himself to death
that night he was so worried about
testifying yeah in boston that he just
couldn't take it anymore and maybe i
don't know what he did but maybe he did
yeah
choked on his own they choked on his own
vomit or something
stuff like that usually od yeah well he
was a old drunk and he's probably in his
70s i don't you know i don't i think the
coroner said his
heart attack or something like that
but yeah so that was you know that's the
kind of case it was you know we had all
this evidence we had to fly back to
boston i'm saying oh great they're going
to bring the
director's jet for me right because i
had to get on a conference call with the
director of the fbi robert mueller that
next morning he's you know they got to
fly out his g5 to pick me up with all
the evidence
commercial no they put out they brought
up this propeller plane from canada
flew on that thing like okay it's like
being on a military transport i go we're
going right to boston now we're not
going boston we're going to manassas i
got to go to boston no i'm going to land
on manassas
i go i go to manassas
who's uh maybe the g5 is coming to get
me and manassas take me to boston make a
great entrance now it's a little cessna
when two got boston agents flying i said
hey guys do you see how much stuff i
have to load in there i've got like 33
boxed up weapons 820 000 cash
i said we're going to fit and assess i
get you know well you know i don't know
we'll see you know my weight their
weight all this evidence and then it
starts to rain and i say guys uh have
you ever flown into logan airport at
night before no not really at night in
the rain so oh
[ __ ] oh my god
i will say robert mueller you know for
whatever's been said about him you know
we had we had a little bit of a
confrontational call that morning i was
kind of tired i didn't want to do a call
for the director of the fbi and told one
of the bosses why don't you do it i got
to get whitey to court no no he wants to
speak to you all right
a little confrontational call i will get
into that but we got a couple months
later he saw me over in orlando at a
conference and he you know singled me
out in front of everybody hey stand up
says i was at ausa in boston when all
this went down and the corruption on the
fbi so i want to thank you personally
for the bottom of my heart for getting
them hooked up said it's been a long
standing black guy for the fbi yeah so
and thanks for doing the job getting
hooked up
that's awesome man yeah that's crazy
that's a great case and just let that uh
that the picture of the woman on
the high def pictures of her that these
couple of great agents uh one of them's
retired um
and they said you know they they were
bringing fbi agents back for years on
these temporary duty assignments to try
and you know get fresh eyes on the case
they finally transferred two guys to
boston said that's all we want you to
work on and they did and some one of
them said hey
there's a doctor that's got some high
def uh plastic surgery photos you know
pre-op photos we got them they put those
on somebody had the idea to do a public
service announcement bureau had to pay
but then air all over they aired only in
14 markets and the person eventually one
person who eventually saw it was
overseas somewhere
and saw the uh cnn uh rebroadcast
and that's uh that's the call that came
in to la and to dc into boston did that
person have to uh
they got the reward i wouldn't sword was
paid and were they
protected
or there were some issues about you know
uh they felt they made life was in
danger but you know it wasn't that why
he had no connections at that point he
was on the run everybody disowned him
right they knew he was an informant
because they'd been publicized that he
was cooperating with the fbi against the
italians so yeah he had no connections
at that point you know he had distanced
himself allegedly from his family so so
i think we got
they boston was able to get over the
hump with the person and
don't worry about it he'll be okay right
so that's beautiful man that's awesome
well yeah 10 most wanted hook and then
you know we did a few more for the
sheriff's department i put some uh guy
who shot two sheriff's deputies back in
98 put him on our tennos one of us got
him hooked up a guy killed who was that
guy mcd sniper mcdeo preciado shot
shot deputies uh scopping
timberlake in whittier and i want to say
it was 98
uh opened up the van is they were
pulling through a traffic stop on a van
he slides open the door
yeah yeah scott yeah and uh sniper
emigrio preciata gets out with an ak
gets stopped on the head
yeah he got in the head i was the lt on
the shooting then you were yeah yeah and
went to the crime scene they had the
crime scene nailed down
and went to uh the hospital there in
linwood saint francis where they had
scop and i asked him if they had
flown the helicopter pick up his wife
and they said no we need to get a
commander's device
get it out there now and tell him i said
get it out there
and knowing it took captain above and i
wasn't the captain or but commander bub
to get the helicopter
i said you just tell them that i said
they i want to honor now
and i'll take the it's easier to say i'm
sorry than to try and ask for permission
right yeah so i should do it and use my
name and we got it out there and
i saw scop recently he's he's still he's
doing good good what was the guy with
the uzi protecting because it's just a
bunch of south side gangsters you know
south side whittier gangsters in a van
didn't want to get stopped he comes out
so he goes on to run
[ __ ] for years i want to say 98 maybe
that that case was and we finally got
him 2009 in some little village
um
outside of puerto vallarta again punta
mita i think was a town he was living
like you know living a little hut
without power doing fishing
that's what we doing but that was just
you know good good lake work by our fbi
guys stationed in mexico
and the little dudes in the hut doing
fishing and then he sees
yeah he's whenever what's going to
happen to him he's got to just maybe
he's got somebody recently down now i
want to say ensenada papas and beer
some guy that had killed his girlfriend
over here
shanked drawn up went down and he
escaped he was gone and
uh they talked him into doing they
talked to friends into doing a facebook
thing you know looking for this guy
justice for whatever her name was
and they found him down
he was working as a waiter and papas and
beer that has to be within the last
three to six months yeah no
i mean that's that's all we have you
know too many of those domestic violence
cases we worked you know killing the
girlfriend and stuff like that the one
another we did in uh another 98 one was
um
joe signs um from east l.a kills two
rivals in city of l.a
that's that's a city k la pedigo goes
over to uh um
east l.a area ray picks up his
girlfriend
takes him back to grandma's place on
eagle street and he still like rapes her
murders her
and then takes off disappears and then
same thing on the run 2008 comes up here
kills the guy in whittier on videotape
turns out he's working for the cartel in
mexico in the intervening time [ __ ] the
guy lost 500 grand of his money so you
can't come up and take care of business
caught him and uh
guadalupe chased him in in guatemala for
two weeks
then went to guadalajara chased him for
two weeks in guadalajara come home
thanksgiving day
i get the call from the mexican police a
couple hours later i'm cutting the
turkey we got him fine wow
fly down the next morning bring him back
how did they get him uh just we got just
somebody's song somebody somebody knew
back in the day hey this guy maybe you
know check this place out guatemala
check el salvador
and it's a big trance you know what they
call that
a transport route from uh you know from
columbia for the cocaine
when they go in through uh
chiapas uh from guatemala from the
border to chiapas into mexico and then
they pipe it up
but yeah crazy case i don't think it's
and it's 2012 only it's going to trial
yet so i can't talk too much about it do
you think do you think that um now with
that with the computers and finger tip
vape voice recognition all that stuff
that
it it's a double-edged sword easier and
harder it makes it easier for us
sometimes it makes it a lot harder right
you can get on the phone and you know go
go through the internet uh from a
internet cafe somewhere and you know do
your business and we can't track it to
you all right right before when i
started we're doing pay phones right
everybody we had we had pagers we were
trapping guys with home land lines yeah
pay phones and that's how we're doing it
right so it's a double-edged sword you
know technology is good in some respects
and there's still how many how many
people would you say that was still out
there like
that
the fbi is actively pursuing uh
thousands of thousands right right right
right right right right right right
thousand yeah thousand watts but there's
all different types right and you know
we obviously have the ten most wanted
list and we have all just most wanted
and then you know you have your regular
ncic probably has
20 000 warrants maybe yeah you know from
things as simple as uh failure to appear
on a
court for something for a dui
did they replace you in the task force
when you retired yeah so i mean we knew
you know 57 is your expiration date at
the fbi right you have to retire so i i
knew a couple of years before
and over the 22 years i did the fugitive
stuff you know some days some years i'd
worked with a partner
many years we didn't wow and then as i
was getting through that ripe old age i
said we gotta get somebody to train them
up see i had a couple of guys
you know probably the last two years
before i retired i stayed i stayed
actually in extension i was almost 58 by
the time i left they extend you three
three times
uh and then you go but yes i had a great
guy uh replaced me in fact
the year before i retired we're doing an
arrest on us
71 year old vato in uh in newton
division just had killed his uh killed
his nephew and the nephew shot his
nephew's friend over a dispute about
kicking him out of the property no
criminal history 71 years old son was
lapd ascot won't be a problem
we line up in the breezeway of the motel
to take him down and
he sees us comes out
goes around the corner with a sick shot
boom boom boom
hits my partner and his wrist it's
another guy in a shotgun flashlight
luckily whoa and then the third a third
one goes over everybody's head into the
wall
and then a couple of guys in front took
him out here's a guy 71 years old your
age gill
no criminal history just like you you
like me no criminals boots pants
he had the high socks you know he said
that
sucks well let me tell you that third
shot would have had my ass running home
for the [ __ ] division you'd still be
running i'd still be running i'm just
fascinated man yeah but that's so the
guy that replaced me winds up getting
shot like a year later but he's a you
know he's a swat guy marine guy yeah
tough as nails yeah you know so uh but
yeah great great investigator great kid
i think those you know some of those
guys like that
they know what they'll they know what's
coming so you're almost like all right
[ __ ] it like i'm out here because i'm
like i can't do that right like you know
that right you're not you don't want to
get it he had a note in his wallet said
uh have my daughter take my body
so he knew he wasn't going to be but you
know
listen my partner got shot but
i think he was going to be suicide by
compliment had he been stopped by a
black and white just on the street you
know so it could have been some poor
copper right absolutely right now we
knew we knew that hey the guy's going to
be arms at least you know but he got the
drop on us but yeah did his kid know
no his kid and him were strange and
that's the other thing and you know
these kids lapd i couldn't he ain't
gonna shoot at the police right so
but yeah best laid plans like we talked
about yeah i think nothing ever goes as
planned no kid yeah i think i think uh
you know when sometimes we don't people
are so good at it when they go you had
no idea and you're like i honestly if
somebody were to lie to you you could
tell that they were lying but you know
you could see that sometimes people are
really paying attention to
the surroundings they're worried about
you know everybody drives the same way
to work it does kind of like have these
these lives where there's not a lot of
alter alternate stuff so
you know they're not really kind of
focusing on other people people get
desperate when you corner them they just
get you know they get desperate and they
want to they want to shoot and um like
rats like rats yeah we had this other
case from vegas a
guy just done 12 years on a murder got
out
kills his buddy steals a whole cache of
weapons gets here we track him down to
santa ana
so we're sitting on a place in santa ana
late at night nine o'clock at night a
couple of uh santa ana cops i'm sorry
yeah standing out of cops they swing by
hey you guys um i need some help yeah
we've got nothing to do tonight right
and so yeah we'll see we'll sit with you
guys so they sat with us car comes out
of the place we're watching
our guys looking the points darks ah i
don't think it's our guy but you know
maybe have the black and white do a
traffic stop just eliminate it
corporal and the sergeant take off
they're gonna do a low key traffic stop
just make sure it's not our guy
corporal uh car makes a left turn by the
gas station corporal follows him
sergeant somehow makes a u-turn gets a
little lost in traffic i get stopped at
the light so i'm just watching next
thing i know the back seat of the car uh
opens up guy gets out with an ak starts
blast about to turn around last round
right as he's turning the corporal sees
this in three rounds boom boom boom gets
him three times puts him down
and this guy would just you know just
get out of a prison or 12 years and you
know kill somebody else even everyone's
going to go back no another time that's
the guy we you know probably save the
highway patrol guy from getting killed
right this guy gets pulled over in the
middle of santa ana
you know gordon grove wherever it was
and you wouldn't see that you wouldn't
see it no
they just had one today
a uh high patrol pulling over uh
checking on a stranded motorist on the
105 710 northbound interchange
and the guy comes out and it starts and
he was a murder suspect
highway patrol didn't know it right but
they were looking at him for murder and
he fortunately
he lost
a chp officer they're putting out on the
news they took grey's wound to the
facebook all right
so what happened in tucson right dea
going on the train to uh just do a
regular routine uh drug interdiction
and as all of a sudden shots of fire on
the train one dea dead one wounded one
cop
and who was that the guy was on the
train two guys on a train probably it
was a train from tucson and new orleans
probably you know a lot of dope is
smuggled on the trains these days and um
really you know they they do regular
interdiction stops bring the dog on
sniffing down
i've never even thought of never
never thought of trains and and the
hound the greyhound that's another way
is that right the hound
wow
yeah so yeah one dea dead one wounded
and one tucson pd wounded
and the bad guy dead
it's a video good video on the uh they
released on it
not crazy was a good guy
oh my goodness crazy stuff that's
bananas beautiful and now sort of found
a second career second life as a uh was
the term technical consultant for uh for
a couple of shows right yeah i most
wanted clarice yeah so as i uh you know
as you get to that point where you're
you know i'm looking for jobs right
because i knew i had i was at the end of
my first extension i knew i had two more
and i didn't want to go do something i
didn't want to do so i get a call from a
buddy of mine who's uh
you know he's a producer in hollywood
i've worked with the years before just
to help him out and he says hey i'm
doing a show called all rise he said you
want to be a tech advisor i said yeah
let me see the script and i said that's
you know not really my wheelhouse it's
about a state judge i'm a federal guy
right he says well i know the people
that are doing fbi most wanted they said
let me put you in touch with them i want
to met the producer yeah when can you
start sure we can't moonlight fbi agents
are not allowed like gil right you're
not out to moonlight and do your day job
so i said i guess i got to retire so i
wound up doing both shows and uh
retiring like probably about a month
after i got the job september of 19.
and uh yeah then clarice i picked
clarice up uh after that and that got
cancelled this year
and uh hopefully all rise comes back
and then i've been doing did the
chippendales documentary i'm supposed to
do
they want to do the show on whitey
bulger and i'm supposed to
do something on that and just do a uh
like a pitch for that we'll see that's
awesome that's great yeah i'm happy uh
you know get up in the morning going
down to the coffee shop talk to some
buddies
you know read a script here and there
there you go like gil goes over to the
vfw [ __ ]
runs them out with some guys yeah
once it goes to the coffee shop i don't
find this fbi stuff that interests you
why it is i've seen you
anything go down over there fritz that
topless
place over there yeah that was the [ __ ]
hey that's you know bad well
we can't say the name but
it was so bad i wouldn't go in there
and i'd go in almost anywhere
you got an early age get my grandfather
out of the bars
[ __ ] a little kid in there going grandma
wants to see that get that [ __ ] out
what's that where is she all right i'll
be right there
yeah it's fascinating man thank you
brother for coming on yeah that's good
stuff yeah you're right gil yeah 100
dude that's right
awesome thanks the guys like you know
guys like gil homicide detectives have
kept me busy over the years right yeah
without those guys making the case
i'd be doing nothing and then you you
know you forge uh friendships that last
you know business professional whatever
you know and i talked about detectives
more than i talked to fbi agents yeah
right awesome it's great that's good
stuff
all right awesome all right good thank
you that's all right well done
you